yeah on the album um
fall is a record that i thought was
really dope because you know the first
verse is you rapping from the
perspective of like an upcoming female
artist who you know and i do think that
that's something that's
kind of unsaid in music like i even
think like
when we think of female mcs like
i think like and it's unfortunate like
rhapsody is on the album yeah and
rhapsody to me is the best
yeah to me and one of the best overall
overall seasons like i think she's like
top five
at at very very minimum top 10 mc's
period
no no she's like yeah she's up there but
like as a female she's like this
she's like yeah she's but i feel like it
sucks because she's not
overly sexualized people don't give her
that respect and that's
not like i i give her that respect but i
feel like
because she's not an overly sexualized
female artist that's a fact she doesn't
get the respect that she deserves
and that's just kind of like the the
world we're [ __ ] in like you know
what i'm saying this is
it's tough like but i thought that was
dope like
like was there anybody in mind like when
you wrote that like like you don't got
to see anybody's name but was there
something well actually
um rap that's how we met so when that
verse on on fall which i personally
think is the most important record on
the album because of that
um that verse about female mcs and about
and the second verse yeah in the second
verse too as well you get them saying
and um
uh but uh unfortunately because of what
we just talked about
i was a late rap city fan i didn't get
put on to layla's wisdom and i'm on tour
with rock and i'm listening
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ] like like
she is crazy yeah
her and kendrick had been putting in
work for like 10 years and i didn't i
was just wasn't hip you know what i mean
and so
um i wrote the verse and i actually even
say on the verse i say i had a convo
with layla
sharing some of her wisdom with me came
to kick it with me so i wrote it from
her perspective and i didn't write the
second verse yet and she was following
me on twitter
and so i just reached out to her and was
like hey i wrote a verse about you like
i just want to send it to you so that
you can hear it like
it's special to me and um i sent it to
her and she called me and she said that
she started tearing up listening to her
because she
she had stories about that where people
were talking to her and telling her how
she needs to like sexualize herself a
little bit more and she was just trying
to stick to the core
and she said you know that whole she
just want to be artist like she felt
that like because that's all she she was
like i just wanted to rap
and make music you know what i mean and
so that's how we made our
our connection and then after that a
couple months later was when i sent her
i can make it and then you know we ended
up doing that so she was definitely the
one that was on the so she was the she
was only one
she was the main mention behind that
entire yeah for sure that's what i
thought when i heard it i was like yo
this [ __ ] like
just reminds me of like like because
i've been a rhapsody fan for so long
yeah um and you know
it just i i was like how is she not more
respected and it's really like
it's just because we have such a shallow
industry that we're in and really just
like fans are so
also shallow my fans are shallow yeah
you know what i'm saying like not every
fan like it you know it's unfortunate